el consejo de la Administración
legislativa de la asamblea nacional
admitió a trámite la solicitud de juicio
político contra el presidente Guillermo
lasso luego de verificar el cumplimiento
de requisitos legales para la solicitud
la sesión de verificación concluyó con
cinco votos a favor y dos abstenciones
el juicio político contra el presidente
ha superado su primer filtro la decisión
se tomó con base a los votos de los
asambleístas del partido social
cristiano antiguos Aliados del
presidente una fracción de la corriente
indígena pachakuti y de la mayoría por
la unión por la esperanza fracción
parlamentaria que agrupa al correísmo
dos atenciones se produjeron por parte
del gobierno aliados y la izquierda
democrática el presidente de la asamblea
tendrá tres días para remitir la
solicitud a la corte constitucional
mientras que la corte deberá sortear el
juez que se encargará de emitir el
informe de procedencia o no del pedido
de juicio político contra Guillermo
lasso un proceso que demorará 55 días de
ser aprobado paralelamente los
movimientos indígenas han convocado sus
bases y las organizaciones sociales para
realizar plantones frente a la corte
constitucional y expresarse una vez que
esta emita su dictamen mientras que por
el gobierno el ministro Henry pucalón
anunció que el presidente no tendrá
limitantes para convocar en cualquier
momento una disolución de la asamblea
nacional lo que significaría una
convocatoria anticipada a elecciones
generales en